hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery Star Wars Episode
seven review now most of you might not
have seen it yet I am gonna do a spoiler
review later in the week with Easter
eggs there is a new round of the
giveaway I'm still giving away free
movie tickets so all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's a gift
certificate for the value of two imax
tickets which is about fifty bucks but
let's get going and they shall take away
totally love this movie I totally
expected to like it going into it there
wasn't anything that completely
disappointed me yeah there were a few
things that I felt could have been
better this is very much a JJ Abrams
movie so if you don't like JJ Abrams
movies then you'll probably have the
same complaints that you have of other
JJ Abrams movies and I feel like across
the board all the characters are perfect
especially the new characters there's
some of the most interesting characters
to come into the Star Wars universe that
I've ever seen I don't want to throw
original trilogy or prequel characters
under the bus but I feel like kylo Ren
is the character that Anakin Skywalker
was meant to be during the prequels he's
not your typical villain he has very
complex motivations and I cannot wait to
see his character develop through
episode eight and nine just like the
other characters are and that's one of
the best things about the characters is
that there's no clear good or evil like
everyone is very very complex a lot of
you guys that have been tweeting at me
at the movie about Poe Dameron and say
that he's your favorite new character
you know you can't wait to hear more
about him I would say of all the
characters he's the closest to being
lawful good in terms of alignment you
know very poppy very Flash Gordon type
of character always thinks of his
friends first never buckles under
pressure
always happy to throw himself into
danger to help someone out Finn is
hilarious he gets all the best funny
moments John boyega absolutely crushed
it and it's heartbreaking as some of the
twists are you feel that instant
connection between him and the other
main characters like you cannot wait to
see them do more stuff together if you
have seen the movie then it's probably
no surprise that Daisy Ridley is my
favorite character coming out of this
Rey's character now because this is
supposed to be a non-spoilery review all
say is that she completely succeeds in
turning a lot of the tropes of the Star
Wars universe on their head
she is the hero that you're looking for
and in being a hero she doesn't undercut
any of the other characters either like
no one character gets development at the
expense of another character nobody gets
thrown under the bus
despite fish shaking you might here in
the back row
the real task of this movie was to
reignite the Star Wars universe to
create something that's completely
independent from the other Star Wars
movies while at the same time honoring
them with a certain amount of continuity
now it doesn't completely throw the
prequel stuff away but it mostly invokes
things from the original trilogy so when
you're looking for Easter eggs mostly
think about original trilogy stuff but
Abrams completely succeeded at the task
I feel one of the weaknesses of the
movie one of the very few weaknesses is
that there are a couple leaps in logic
that the movie asks you to make but I
feel like the only reason that happens
is because they cut a lot of scenes all
of Abrams films have this real sense of
kinetic energy that this Star Wars movie
definitely has but in order to do that
you have to lose a lot of connective
tissue that you find in films to move a
little bit slower a little more
deliberately so one of the big strengths
of the movie also leads to one of its
weaknesses
seriously the movies a little under two
and a half hours if it were like a three
hour movie I think it'd feel like
there's less connective tissue that's
missing just in terms of logic and drop
plot points but usually you can forgive
that especially if you're seeing it for
the first time you know maybe if it's
the fifth time you're seeing the movie
you might start pointing out some of the
flaws a little bit more and I think
it'll be easier to compare the quality
of this film to Episode eight when
that's released just because this is so
different from the other Star Wars
movies because in terms of visual style
what's going on in the galaxy that I
think it's like comparing apples to
oranges to try and compare this to the
prequels or the original trilogy but I
will say that Empire still my favorite
Star Wars movie this is my second
favorite Star Wars movie now what about
bb-8 we have to talk about him a little
bit though he has to feel some very
large TreadMarks for r2d2 and I actually
just found out I laughed so hard
Bill Hader and Ben Schwartz who was John
Rafi Oh from Parks and Rec did the voice
for bb-8 I mean I mean they've modified
their voices quite a bit but Abram said
that when they were creating the droid
bb-8 they wanted a droid companion that
made sounds that children could mimic
that you know you can like you can see
little kids walking around making the
sounds so whenever you see bb-8 rolling
around just picture John Rafi oh and
Bill Hader just making funny noises into
like a little microphone and even though
you do connect with the human
performances the most there is a lot of
motion capture characters like Maz
Kanata or Supreme Leader Snoke
I feel like Lupita was awesome Andy
circuses perform
always go without saying he is one of
the most amazing motion capture artists
in the world Snoke is a good example of
a character that you can't really talk
about with getting into spoilers so I'll
talk about him more during my Easter Egg
video but there's going to be a lot to
unpack from this movie because it in no
way answers every single question that
you have like it all of you actually
here's my question for you guys
write it in the comments what was your
biggest question coming out of the movie
or maybe even going into the movie did
that change going in and coming out like
were there big questions that you had
that the movie didn't answer it's the
intention of Lucasfilm to like slowly
answer some of these questions through
the trilogy in the spin-off films but a
lot of the expanded material too so like
the novel's will pick up a lot of the
slack now some people might consider
that lazy storytelling but I just feel
like it's fun for us to try and figure
those things out like sometimes it's
worse when everything gets explained so
take that as a challenge tumblr start
answering as many questions as possible
I know I haven't talked a lot about the
original trilogy characters there's only
so much that we can talk about them you
know without getting into spoilers but
han and Leia like we've seen them in the
trailer so I'll talk about them there is
some very poignant cry worthy moments
that they have in the film and without
necessarily explaining what the dynamic
is between them there is so much energy
between them when they're on-screen
together it's so amazing but in the
realest of terms one of the other big
jobs of this movie was to pass the torch
to the new characters it did an amazing
job of doing that
so as excited as you are to have seen
this movie if you haven't seen it yet
when you're walking out of it you will
probably be even more excited to see
what happens in Episode eight now here's
the next thing you need to get really
excited about - like if there's if
there's certain JJ Abrams tropes that
you're not really happy about like some
of the film techniques that he uses he's
amazing at finding talent writing
characters but you know there's always
like you know minor techniques like like
lens flare yo is gets criticized for or
there even like a few of the cg scenes
that kind of take you out of the action
just because they're like they're just
too overblown but remember Rian Johnson
is directing and writing episode 8 so JJ
Abrams will only loosely be involved so
if some of your bigger complaints are JJ
Abrams specific complaints then those
have already been answered so there's no
need to worry what I'm probably going to
be doing next is a spoilery review with
Easter eggs look just like a spoilery
Easter egg
video kind of more in like the top 10
WTF format that I normally do but I'll
also do videos for each of the big
characters that we could talk about them
all day I know I said raised characters
my favorite kylo Ren also like really
close second with Poe Dameron like
they're all just so amazing so if you
haven't already let me know in the
comments who is your favorite character
coming out of this film and have you
seen it more than once already I know
it's only been out for a couple days but
I'm always curious to see if like
anybody just stays in the theater and
watches multiple viewings just and
things there was this really huge
comment that Lucas made when he was
making the prequels for he's like they
rhyme you know they rhyme with the
original trilogy that's a way of saying
that there are a lot of familiar story
beats familiar characters familiar
things you know like visually and
thematically they rhyme with the
original trilogy so this film also
rhymes a lot with the original trilogy
but you could also say that at certain
points it almost rhymes a little too
much but I don't I don't think that that
hurts the film at all I think that's
part of the intention it's just meant to
be the connective tissue between the
other films that have come before in
this new universe that they're spinning
out so I'm expecting the newer films to
go into much more uncharted territory
just in terms of places we visited the
way environments look the types of ships
that we see I mean it's always going to
be familiar because it's Star Wars but
it's a big galaxy and we have not seen
all of it not even close yet now I know
I said empires my favorite Star Wars
movies still I'm curious to see if
episode 8 winds up being the Empire of
the new trilogy
I feel like Rian Johnson is sweating
just feeling like he's gonna be compared
to Empire so much so while you wait for
my spoilery Star Wars Easter Egg video
to post you can click here for all my
other episode 7 videos I have like a
giant playlist and you can click here to
learn all about the twelve days of
Deadpool thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I will see you
in line for Star Wars again in a couple
days